مجموعه العشرين من اجل السلام في اوكرانيا
مبادره طرحها الرئيس البرازيلي على
الطاوله من ابوظبي حيث كان يزور الشيخ
محمد بن زايد ال نهيان
نصب نفسه وسيطا لحل الصراع الاوكراني
الروسي
تحدثت عن الحرب مع الشيخ محمد بن زايد ال
نهيان لقد تحدثت عن الحرب
معتقد اننا وجدنا مجموعه من الناس يفضلون
الحديث عن السلام عوضا عن الحرب اعتقد ان
الامور ستنجح
ياتي الاعلان في الوقت الذي يقوم فيه لولا
بجولات رسميه لزياره الشركاء قبل الامارات
ذهب الى الصين في زياره امتدت ليومين
يتحدث من مبدا واحد من الضروري معامله
بوتين باحترام كبير لاقناعه بتحقيق السلام
كما لم يتردد في انتقاد واشنطن واوروبا
بسبب دورهما في الصراع يجب على الولايات
المتحده التوقف عن تشجيع الحرب والبدء في
الحديث عن السلام ويجب على الاتحاد
الاوروبي ان يبدا بالحديث عن السلام من
اجل اقناع بوتين بان السلامه في مصلحه
العالم باسره
يريد الرئيس البرازيلي ان يجمع بين الدول
التي ظلت حتى الان محايده في الصراع
الخلافا لقوى غربيه عده لم تفرض للصين ولا
البرازيل ولا الامارات عقوبات ماليه على
روسيا وتحافظ البرازيل على علاقات مميزه
مع موسكو في اطار مجموعه البريكس فيرفض
لولا باستمرار انتقاد الرئيس الروسي ولكنه
لا يتردد في فعل ذلك بخصوص زيلينتكي بل
واقترح لولا الاسبوع الماضي ان تتنازل
اوكرانيا عن شبه جزيره القرم لروسيا لبدء
مفاوضات سلام فكره رفضتها الحكومه فيكياف
تماما